vous avez déclaré mais s'il faut oui
c'est que je ne suis pas chanceux nié je
préfère avoir l'air que de balancer mon
petit couplet c'est à dire rien c'est
bien alors vous allez avoir l'air on va
faire un truc alors je signale à nos
amis présents ici on peut bouger pendant
le jingle maintenant à bon compte
mais vous n'êtes
pas bougé pendant le jingle que
maintenant il avait pu à bouger pendant
ce soir exceptionnellement ont peu bougé
pendant le jingle et super conditionné
thierry tu sais voilà alors donc c'est
une interview sans la bouche donc je
vous posais des questions et vous allez
me répondre sans parler c'est une
interview sans la bouche de quelle
humeur et vous le matin quand vous vous
réveillez
oui d'accord
d'accord moi j'aimerais pas trois buts
avec
quelle est la première chose que vous
faites en vous levant
quelle est votre position préférée pour
prendre votre petit déjeuner
jeudi
imaginons c'est un peu comme dans votre
livre d'alain coupe d'un couple de notre
temps là votre fille vous annonce
qu'elle est enceinte vous réagissez
comme en
pire et si c'est votre fils qui vous
annonce qu'il est en simple magie c'est
comment
je n'aurais pas trouvé de son fils
étudiant sur un
imaginaire c'est comme dans le film les
insaisissables de questions un initié
débarque chez vous faites quoi
vous sortez dans la rue matin il ya un
clochard qui vous demandent l'aumône
voulu donner une petite pièce et il vous
dit que c'est pas assez vous réagissez
comment
tout fonctionne vous arrivez sur le
tournage de la vérité de tout le monde
c'est tout le monde se marre tout ça en
vous voyant et vous savez pas pourquoi
d'accord pensez à quoi donc je vais pas
alors au déjeuner il ya une figurante
qui vous drague
vous êtes du genre à couper court tout
de suite oui
mais cette phase on avait dit qu'on n'en
parlait pas mais non même temps je suis
un peu voilà donc après une journée de
tournage vous rentrez chez vous et le
clochard vous insulte à nouveau publié
pas devenir c'est le matin votre femme
vous annonce qu'elle est enceinte de
l'huissier et vous vous péter les plombs
c'est comment quand vous pétez les plans
et de montrer que tu as l'air
les gagnantes et lola
pour la wii
on rallume merci donc je lui ai dit qu'à
no
mercy qui
viendra s'asseoir dans un ballet du
grand contre le patin dégonfle pas c'est
bon c'est bon j'ai senti l'énergie alors
après écoute pendant toute l'émission je
me trompe et le pousse
pas perdre mon temps tu vois c'est vrai
j'ai un panaris vélo
c'est pour ça que j'ai demandé de l'eau
propre
vas-y tiré fait un gros plan sur mon
pouce pas fait un gros plan sur le pouce
du pmi les gros perdants c'est bien bas
reste comme ça jusqu'à la fin
dans une caméra diverger serge sur la la
c'est bon là soit les corrections de ne
rien rater de l'inaptitude abonnez vous
il m'était impossible eux